[Musique]
ça a été deux heures d'autosatisfaction
d'émotion de séduction largement sur
jouer on ne fait rien bouger si on est
pas et reid un respect infini pour
chacun et je pense que vous ne céderez
spa l'époque et je pense que dans
certaines de mes deux mais certains de
mes propos j'ai blessé des gens puis y
est donc majeur que ce format télévisuel
marche encore on verra les audiences à 9
heures mais à mon avis ça fera moins de
deux millions et demi déception pour le
président de la république on vous le
disait cette émission de deux heures
enregistré dimanche n'a pas atteint les
4 millions de téléspectateurs président
de la république je crois un bhl
déterminer qui a fait un bilan également
de son action qu'à tracer des
perspectives pour l'avenir des choses
très fort sur la réforme des retraites
par exemple qui a été dit sur le co
ville moderne de candidats sur la
réforme des retraites emmanuel macron
parle surtout de lui et assez peu de la
france
baisse de 2,2 numéro de narcissisme
assez marquée de nombrilisme même quand
on va deux heures à la télévision à
quatre mois d'une élection
présidentielle et qu'on dit trois fois
je ne suis pas candidat on n'est pas
sincère l'a pas dit je ne suis pas
candidat si l'a pas dit comme ça ben
c'est ce que ça aussi c'était la
question lui a été posée quatre fois
hélas 4 x 4 file n'a pas répondu il a
fait des choses qui sont pas faciles à
faire pour quelqu'un de public pour
quelqu'un en général c'est reconnaître
des erreurs s'est présenté des excuses
et a pas présenté d'excusés s'il a dit
si j'ai blessé des gens alors je le
regrette excuses la légende ou très
authentique je pense d'ailleurs qu'à
certains moments il l'a dit aussi donc
dans le passé est en réalité cette
phrase elle vaudrait pour nous tous dans
la vie je crois que vous avez laissé qui
vous blessez parfois sans vous en rendre
compte tout simplement on sent qu'il a
envie de faire une espèce de mea culpa
et je sais pas comment dire ça c'est pas
gentil mais ça sonne faux je sais pas
comment vous l'avez perçu elle vous
avait choqué ses phrases enfin je dirais
pas ça je pense qu'elles ont
effectivement ils lui ont été reprochés
et c'était important voilà qui montre
qu'il est conscient que ça a pu blesser
certains français moi j'ai trouvé en
revanche cette phrase
j'ai appris à mieux aimer
les français terrible en fait tu est
terrible parce que on n'apprend pas
aimer les français ou les aime quand
vous avez des oppositions qui nous est
black en permanence oui de manière très
laurent malhonnête c'est d'accord mais
nous ce qu'on aimerait évidemment c'est
pouvoir leur répondre en tout point on
ne peut pas le faire précisément parce
qu'on n'est pas en campagne le président
de la république a voulu purger tout le
mépris qu'il a affichée pour les
françaises et les français pendant ce
quinquennat
donc c'est bien une émission de campari
nous y sommes quasiment à l'obligation
vaccinale quand vous avez plus de 90% de
celles et ceux qui doivent se faire
vacciner qui se sont fait vacciner on
regardera avec pragmatisme dans les
prochaines semaines mais cette hypothèse
existe il ya ceux qui sont censés être
des sachants et qui répandent de la
fausse information cela cela ils doivent
payer un jour pour ça parce que ils ont
pardonné mois pour l'expression du sang
sur les mains donc je ne crois pas au
grand remplacement passait pas une croix
il ne il n'est pas là ce qui est vrai
c'est que ces dernières décennies nous
n'avons pas bien intégrés vous savez le
coin en remplacement c'est pas une thèse
fumeuse ou complotistes c'est simplement
un processus un processus de
remplacement de population par une autre
nous sommes obligés
de réduire à 1 tgv sur 2 le plan de
transport de vendredi je tiens à le dire
d'un mot extrêmement simple
c'est scandaleux adjoint de l'histoire
on la connaît la fin c'est ça c'est que
ça va soit une privatisation soit ils se
réveillent ils arrêtent d'en bas voilà
tout simplement et personne personne ne
les seuls qui sont ces cornes personne
ne les plaindra et ils auront eux-mêmes
creuser leur propre leur propre tombe
la grève est levée mais la journée
s'annonce tout de même compliquée demain
pour les usagers avec ici gare de lyon
seulement 1 tgv sur 2 au départ
mon arbre à l'essor
[Musique]
en tête